Fire And Blood will reign again and you can
expect to see the Blackfyre Rebellions in
the later seasons of House of the Dragon!
That includes one of the most prominent and
key figures from this time period,
Brynden ''Bloodraven'' Rivers who was the
main Targaryen general fighting against Blackfyres.
The same man who would later go on to become
the three-eyed raven and teach Bran Stark
his abilities.
The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on George RR
Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
House of the Dragon will start with a build
up towards the Dance of the Dragons and early
seasons will cover the Dance itself. Later
seasons however, will be based on George RR
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book .
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
As I already said, one of the most important
characters from this time period of the Blackfyre
Rebellions was Ser Brynden Rivers, called
"Lord Bloodraven".
He was the bastard son of King Aegon IV Targaryen
by his sixth mistress, Lady Melissa Blackwood.
He had two older sisters and numerous half-siblings.
As his mother was highborn, Brynden was counted
among the Great Bastards.
Like his bastard siblings, Brynden was legitimized
by King Aegon IV in 184 AC.
Brynden's personal arms were a white dragon
with red eyes breathing red flame on a black
field.
Brynden was an albino and thus had milky-white
skin, long white hair, and red eyes.
On the right side of his face he had a red
wine stain birthmark that extended from his
throat up to his right cheek from which he
earned his name Bloodraven,
as the birthmark was said to look somewhat
like a raven drawn in blood.
Brynden was not as tall or muscular as his
half brothers, Daemon Blackfyre and Aegor
Bittersteel,
but he was considered more cunning. Brynden
carried the Valyrian steel longsword Dark
Sister
and was a good swordsman, he was an expert
bowman who preferred to use his tall weirwood
longbow.
Brynden was rumored to be a sinister sorcerer
and spymaster who effectively ruled the kingdom
"with spies and spells" and as "Lord Bloodraven".
A popular riddle asked was,
"How many eyes does Lord Bloodraven have?
A thousand eyes, and one".
The song "A Thousand Eyes, and One" was written
about Brynden.
Brynden was resented by his half brother Aegor
Rivers, nicknamed "Bittersteel".
At some point, Brynden became a lover to his
half-sister, Shiera Seastar.
As Aegor desired her as well, Shiera became
another point of rivalry between the two half-siblings.
Bittersteel became a great champion and general
for his half brother Daemon Blackfyre,
while Bloodraven became a great champion and
general for his half brother Daeron II Targaryen.
The First Blackfyre Rebellion ended in 196
AC with the Battle of Redgrass Field,
in which Daemon Blackfyre and his eldest two
sons were slain.
It was Bloodraven's private company of archers,
known as the Raven's Teeth,
who rained arrows down upon Daemon Blackfyre
and his two eldest sons, killing them.
Many called Bloodraven a kingslayer for this,
although no one knew exactly whose arrows
had killed Daemon - he was pierced by many.
The arrows are said to have been driven by
Brynden's sorcery.
Daemon's death led the rebels to rout, but
some were rallied by Aegor Rivers in mad charge.
The resulting duel between the rival half
brothers left Brynden blinded in one eye and
Aegor retreating.
The battle was lost, but Bittersteel managed
to escape, and became one of the major leaders
of the surviving Blackfyre forces as they
fled into exile in the Free Cities.
Daemon left behind five sons and multiple
daughters, so Bittersteel became their guardian.
They would continue to harass the Seven Kingdoms
with plots and failed rebellions for decades.
After King Daeron II died in the Great Spring
Sickness of 209 AC he was succeeded by his
son Aerys I Targaryen - who proved to be weak,
absentee-king, more concerned with introverted
scholarly pursuits than any form of governing.
When Aerys I was crowned, however, Bloodraven
was named as the new Hand of the King, a position
he held throughout Aerys I's twelve-year reign.
During that time, Bloodraven was the real
power behind the throne, and the functional
ruler of the Seven Kingdoms. Aerys I's rule
was deeply troubled by plague, drought, and
insurrection,
and many blamed Bloodraven because he was
in charge,
but ultimately he was the man holding the
realm
back from the brink of chaos during this troubled
period.
During his time as Hand of the King, Brynden
was not only an effective administrator and
strategist,
but a cunning spy-master, and the information
from his secret agents greatly aided his grip
on power. His spies were so widespread that,
also referring to the eye he lost in battle,
a popular riddle at the time asked, "How many
eyes does Lord Bloodraven have?"
to which the answer was "A thousand eyes...
and one...".
Some people alleged that Brynden and his paramour,
his half-sister Shiera Seastar,
used sorcery to uncover secrets. During the
wedding tourney at Whitewalls in 212 AC,
and through his informants, including a man-at-arms
and a troupe of comic dwarfs,
Brynden was aware of a plot at Whitewalls
to put Daemon II Blackfyre forward as the
legitimate Lord of the Seven Kingdoms.
Brynden marched on the tourney with three
hundred Raven's Teeth, three brothers of the
Kingsguard, five hundred other knights, and
five thousand infantry drawn from the crownlands
and the riverlands.
In the face of such a force Daemon tried to
rally the tourney-goers to battle, but found
little support. Daemon then challenged Bloodraven
to single combat; Brynden refused and arrested
the pretender, thus containing the Second
Blackfyre Rebellion.
Daemon was kept in captivity rather than executed
with the other rebel leaders,
ensuring that Aegor Rivers could not name
his brother Haegon as a serious pretender.
However, Daemon died few years later while
a hostage in the Red Keep,
and Haegon and Bittersteel launched the Third
Blackfyre Rebellion.
The Third Blackfyre Rebellion featured the
second duel between Brynden
and his half brother Bittersteel. At the end
of the final battle, the Pretender Haegon
was dishonorably killed after he had surrendered
and had given up his sword. Bittersteel was
taken captive.
In the aftermath of the Third Blackfyre Rebellion,
Brynden argued that the captive Aegor Rivers
should be put to death, but King Aerys I Targaryen
decided to send Aegor to the Night's Watch
instead. However, Aegor Rivers escaped back
to Essos when his ship was intercepted en
route to Eastwatch,
thus the Blackfyre plotting continued. Brynden
continued as Hand for Aerys's successor,
his brother Maekar I, in 221 AC. After Maekar's
death in 233 AC, Brynden, as the Hand of the
King,
called a Great Council in King's Landing to
discuss disputed matter of succession.
Aerys I died in 221 AC without issue, so he
was succeeded by his younger brother Maekar
Targaryen. Even though Maekar distrusted his
uncle, he kept Bloodraven as Hand of the King.
Maekar ruled for twelve years and was then
succeeded by his own son, Aegon V Targaryen,
also known as "Egg". During the Great Council
that put Aegon V on the throne,
Aenys Blackfyre had sent word from the Free
Cities that he wanted to put himself forth
as a legitimate candidate. Bloodraven promised
him safe passage and Aenys accepted in good
faith,
but as soon as he set foot in King's Landing,
the Gold Cloaks seized him
and dragged him to the Red Keep, where Bloodraven
promptly executed him.
This was decried as utterly dishonorable,
but Bloodraven said he willingly paid the
price to remove one more potential Blackfyre
pretender, and accepted exile to the Night's
Watch as punishment.
In 233 AC, the year he was crowned, Aegon
V had Bloodraven sent north
as part of the "honor guard" that escorted
his older brother, Maester Aemon, to the Wall.
Brynden took Dark Sister with him when he
went to the Wall. In time, Bloodraven rose
to become the new Lord Commander. He served
long and well in this position,
but one day he went out alone ranging beyond
the Wall, and mysteriously never returned.
Around 50 years later Bran Stark discovers
that Brynden is still alive as the three-eyed
crow,
the last greenseer living with children of
the forest in a cave beyond the Wall.
In George RR Martin's books, the three-eyed
raven reveals the following:
''I wore many names when I was quick, but
even I had a mother,
and the name she gave me at her breast was
Brynden.'' He also tells Bran this:
''I have my own ghosts, Bran. A brother that
I loved (which would be Daeron),
a brother that I hated (which would be Bittersteel),
a woman I desired (which would be Shiera).''
The three-eyed raven also said to Bran the
following:
''I have been watching you. All of you. All
of your lives, with a thousand eyes and one.''
We know that a popular riddle asked about
Brynden in his youth was,
"How many eyes does Lord Bloodraven have?
A thousand eyes, and one".
The song "A Thousand Eyes, and One" was written
about Brynden,
so that's a nice little final confirmation
of Lord Bloodraven that he indeed became the
three-eyed raven.
That's the story of the main Targaryen loyalist
fighting against the Blackfyres in the Blackfyre
rebellions, Brynden Rivers known as Lord Bloodraven.
Legendary characters such as Brynden himself
as well as Daemon Blackfyre and Bittersteel
as well as dozens of characters coming before
them in the Dance of the Dragons,
legendary battles such as the Battle of Redgrass
Field and many other coming before and after,
all of that and more this Game of Thrones
prequel show, House of the Dragon, brings
in 2022,
although the rebellions will be in the later
seasons of the show.
Let me know your thoughts about all of this
in the comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching and hope to
see you in the next one.
Peace!